تدافع عن قبيله نهائي خليجي 25 يودي بحياه
شخص في البصره ترامب يقولوا ان فيسبوك خسر
700 مليار دولار بسببه نجاه رجلا تاه في
البحر لاربعه وعشرين يوما والسر في
الكاتشب هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
نبدا من العراق حيث افادت وكاله الانباء
الرسميه بوفاه شخص واصابه العشرات نتيجه
تدافع عنه وقع خارج ملعب البصره الدولي
الذي سيحتضن المباراه النهائيه بين العراق
وسلطنه عمان محافظه البصره كان قد حذر من
احتمال نقل نهائي خليجي 25 خارج العراق في
حال استمرار التدافع لكنه تراجع مؤكدا ان
المباراه في موعدها واشار في حديثنا
للعربيه الى توفير شاشات عملاقه في اكثر
من 11 ساعه لمتابعه المباراه مشددا على ان
الوضع في ملعب الجذع النخله لم يخرج عن
السيطره
ليس لدي ما يكفي من الطاقه بهذه الكلمات
اعلنت رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا جاستيندا
اوردرن انها ستتنحى عن منصبها في موعد
اقصاه اوائل فبراير المقبل ولن تسعى
لاعاده انتخاضها وفي خبر اثار الصدمه لدى
الكثيرين البالغه من العمر 42 عاما قالت
وهي تغالب دموعها ان الاعوام الخمسه
والنصف التي انضطها في رئاسه الوزراء كانت
صعبه وانها مجرد بشر وتحتاج الى التنحيف
مضيفه خلال مؤتمر صحفي لا املك ما يكفي من
الطاقه لاربع سنوات اخرى فيما ستدخل
استقالتها حيزه تنفيذ بمجرد تعيين رئيس
الوزراء جديد
الى امريكا هذه المره حيث قال الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب انا حملته تسعى
للسعاده حسابها على فيسبوك بينما يستعد
لاطلاق حمله ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
عام 2014 وفي مقابله مع قناه فوكس نيوز
اوضح ترامب ان فيسبوك يحتاج الينا اكثر
مما نحتاجه على حد تعبيره زاعما ان المنصه
خسرت 700 مليار دولار منذ ان تم الغاء
حسابه في يناير 2021 مارينا انه يعمل على
ترتيب اجتماعا لمناقشه اعاده تفعيل حسابه
مع الرئيس التنفيذيه لشركه الشركه المالكه
متى ذاكربر
في حادثه تكاد تكون الشبه بافلام السينما
نجا رجل تاه في البحر الكاريبي لاربعه
وعشرين يوما بعدما تناول الكاتشب خلال هذه
المده قبل ان يتم انقاذه وفي مقطع فيديو
نشرته البحريه الكولومبيه قال البس
فرانسوا من جمهوريه الدومينيكان انه لم
تكن لديه اي ماكولات صور عبوه من الكاتشب
ومسحوق الثوم ومكعبات من المرق مشيرا الى
انه خلط كل هذه المكونات مع الماء
وتناولها طيله فتره ضياعه كي يبقى على قيد
الحياه واضاف انه بدا في ارسال اشارات
لطائره راها في السماء من خلال انعكاس
اشعه الشمس على مراه كانت بحوزته لي ثم
انقذه على الفوري
في خبرنا الاخير اعلنت شركه مايكروسوفت
الامريكيه انها تخطط لتسريح 10,000 موظف
في اطار موجه الاستغناء عن العماله التي
تجتاح قطاع التكنولوجيا تقارير اوضحت ان
هذا القرار سيؤثر سيؤثر على 5% من القوى
العامله على مستوى العالم مشيره الى انه
سيكلف الشركه واحد فاصل اثنين مليار دولار
على شكل نفقات بسبب فصل الموظفين واعاده
تنظيم المؤسسات فيما قال الرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه في رساله للموظفين اتخذنا هذه
الخيارات الصعبه لنبقى شركه مهمه في صناعه
لا ترحم الذين لا يتكيفون مع المتغيرات